Oh God hi my name is your biggest fan
I'm stormfront great brace yourself boys
and girls because we have new details
about the boys season two including a
new release date and a new character
reveal so stay tuned if we're gonna
break it all down for you right now on
the catch up the first season of the
boys which is certified fresh' at 84% on
the tomato meter and has an audience
score of 93% was a little bit of a
surprise hit for Amazon when a debuted
last year but the upcoming second season
is now one of the most anticipated shows
of 2020 and for Gore I mean a good
reason my deepest condolences to Robyn's
family she just stepped in the middle of
the street in a live online event hosted
by Patton Oswalt recently who by the way
is slated to appear in season 2 it was
announced that the new season will debut
on September 4th but in a twist
Amazon's usual model only the first
three episodes will be available that
day with the remaining five come in once
a week through October 9th they're
really gonna make us work for this one
guys we also got our first look at a new
major character that is joining the cast
stormfront played by aya cash here I go
you guys wish me luck we learned that
she was chosen to replace translucent in
the 7 and we see her immediately
challenged home Lander and Queen Maeve
while showing off her social media
presence now in the comics storm front
is a loose parody of both Marvel's Thor
and DC Shazam and the leader of the
b-list superhero team called payback the
comics version is also male and a
literal product of the Third Reich so
it's unclear how much if any of that
backstory will carry over to the series
but I'm here for it in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly cash said storm
front is there to blow up fought and
described her as being quite the
feminist and a very empowered woman and
like I said I am here for it new whoo
and new footage shown at the end of
Amazon's online event revealed Giancarlo
Esposito san Edgar settling in as the
new boss of the 7 because of course
Elizabeth's shoes Madeline Stillwell
didn't make it out of season 1 alive
sorry spoiler we also got an extended
look at black noir played by Nathan
Mitchell who's expected
play a much bigger role in the second
season his true identity is one of the
comics big reveals so they could be
building to something similar in the
series
I'm starlight and speaking of the comics
a new trailer released in December shows
a shot of terror Billy the butcher's
Bulldog
so hopefully the fan favorite sidekick
will be around a lot in season two other
new additions to the cast include Goran
vicinage as all sera Donna the shady
leader of occultist Church and Claudia
Duman as an up-and-coming congresswoman
named Victoria Newman and as far as the
story goes showrunner Eric Kripke has
said that superheroes in the military
will still be a big storyline and based
on what we've seen the show will pick up
pretty much for season 1 left off after
it revealed at home Lander has a
super-powered son with Billy's thought
to be dead wife Becca Becca was like
nope I'm still here obviously there's a
major showdown brewing here but each
character will no doubt face new
obstacles in season 2 before hopefully
eventually squaring off
[Applause]
but right now it's time for us to kick
it over to you now are you excited for
the boys season two and who is your
favorite character let us know all your
thoughts and feelings in the comment
section and of course if you're dying
for more streaming or binge guides or
any type of movie related news head on
over to Rotten Tomatoes comm also if you
want to keep talking about storm front
homeland or black noir or any of the
soups let's do it in our fan group on
Facebook so join us and you don't want
to miss out on any future episodes of
the show be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell and as
always thanks guys for watching the
ketchup my name is ass Prez and we
really appreciate your support Stacy
you